>> Sean: YOU ARE DOING A GREAT
JOB.
WE WILL ISSUE WATCHING YOU IN
THE MORNING.
ALSO AT THE BORDER TONIGHT
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN DAN
CRENSHAW.
HE WAS IN BROWNSVILLE, TEXAS, TO
SEE THE SITUATION ON THE BORDER.
HE'S IN McALLEN, TEXAS AND A
SPECIAL AGENT IS WITH US.
I HAVE BEEN DOWN THERE 14 TIMES.
TELL EVERYBODY WHAT YOU SEE.
>> THE BIG TAKE AWAY HERE.
THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR 40% OF TOTAL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN THE
COUNTRY.
IT'S A HUGE SPOT FOR THIS.
IT'S DIVIDED INTO THE 2 SPOTS.
BROWNSVILLE AND McALLEN.
BROWNSVILLE HAS 35 MILES OF
SECURE FENCING.
IT'S BORDER SECURITY THE WAY WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT.
A GOOD MIX OF TECHNOLOGY AND
FENCING.
IN McALLEN YOU HAVE THE
OPPOSITE.
YOU HAVE WIDE OPEN AREAS.
WE SEE ABOUT 6% OF ILLEGAL APPRE
WE SEE ABOUT 6% OF ILLEGAL APP E
APPREMENTIONS HAPPEN IN
BROWNSVILLE.
A LOT HAVE KIDS WITH THEM WHO
WILL BE LET GO IN AMERICA.
>> Sean: IS THIS A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY?
>> OF COURSE, SEAN.
WE HAD ALL OF THAT FENTANYL
SEIZED YESTERDAY.
THAT COULD HAVE KILLED HALF OF
THE VIEWERS OF THE SUPER BOWL.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC HAS TO
REALIZE THAT COULD KILL 500,000
PEOPLE.
IN NEW YORK THEY SEIZED MORE
POISON.
THANK GOD THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARE OUT THERE UNDER-PAID AND
GETTING SHOT AT BY PEOPLE IN
AMERICA.
THANK GOD PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
STANDING UP FOR OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> Sean: WHAT IF THAT COULD KILL
57 MILLION PEOPLE, THE LARGEST
HAUL OF FENTANYL THEY GOT THIS
WEEK.
WHAT IS A TERRORIST ORGANIZATION
GOT AHOLD OF THAT AND WANTED TO
LACE OUR FOOD WITH IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE AIRPLANE IN
THE SEIZURE IN NEW YORK THAT WAS
COMING ON PLANES?
IT'S NOT JUST COMING IN ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THESE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
OPERATIONS, THEY HAVE TO GET
THEIR PRODUCTS INTO AMERICA.
IF IT GETS INTO THE PLANES
VENTILATION SYSTEM OR THE FOOD
SUPPLY.
THIS IS THE THING THE PUBLIC
DOESN'T REALIZE.
THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL ISSUE.
THIS IS THE SECURITY OF OUR
COUNTRY AND OUR KIDS.
>> Sean: BACK TO DAN.
I KNOW YOU ARE STRONG ON THE
ISSUE.
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS HOLDING THE
LINE.
MANY REPUBLICANS WILL, BUT THERE
ARE THOSE WHO HAVE NO BACKBONE.
I HAVE NO RESPECT IF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY DOESN'T BACK
THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE USES THE
MILITARY OR THE EMERGENCY
OPTION.
AS COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, THAT'S
HIS JOB.
HE SCORE AN OATH TO PROTECT OUR
CONSTITUTION, OUR RULE OF LAW.
>> MORE IMPORTANTLY, I AM A
MEMBER OF THE HOMELAND SECURITY
COMMITTEE.
THIS IS NOT THE PRESIDENT'S
PLAN.
THIS PLAN HAS BEEN ON THE BOOK
FOR YEARS.
IT COMES FROM EXERTS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
IT IS WALLS WHERE IT MAKES
SENSE.
THIS IS WHAT THE MEN AND WOMEN
ON THE FRONT LINES ARE ASKING